You look an absolute mess, Daniel.
Make your collar good.
Never have the top
bottom done.
It's too big!
It's too small.
You should rip it in this
shot, you should just be like
so .
I reckon I could rip it.
I could rip that.
Just .
Oh .
You did it on camera .
Oh no .
Hello internet and welcome to my garden.
Hello, Dan I've got a story for you today.
Oh yeah.
In this here video.
I was at my crafting
table just the other day.
Oh yeah yeah.
And I had an iron ingot,
and also a piece of flint
that I found in some gravel.
Were you mining were you?
Yeah, mining.
As you do.
A little bit of mining.
Yeah.
And I put 'em together
on my crafting table
and I came up with a flint and steel
so--
Genius that.
I figured we would film a flint and steel
sparking it up super
close up in slow motion.
Jesus.
Oh.
It actually set--
Oh look at that .
You almost burnt a hole through it.
[Blonde Scientist] I've done
some serious damage there
I think.
Sorry, sorry.
That's not gonna come out.
The frame is like here
and the focus is like that
so try not to move that.
Too much.
Okay.
No pressure.
All right.
Got one?
Yeah.
Let me know when you got a good one.
Okay focus again.
Yeah that's good.
Okay.
Dammit.
Come on.
What you up to?
Right this doesn't work
anything like it does
in Minecraft.
I can't get this woodblock to light.
Oh.
Look,
just doesn't do it.
Hold on.
Give me that.
Whoa!
[Blonde Scientist] See ya!
Well, I've learned a lot today.
Yeah, so if you're ever
exploring with your
flint and steel,
just grab the nearest can of petrol
and there you go.
You got fire.
Yeah.
You really stepped it up a notch.
Oh that is awful.
You didn't just--
See what I did there?
See you later.
I had to mention this.
'Cause hair do here.
Hair do?
He forgot the battery for the camera
so today we're actually filming our intros
on the iPhone.
That is state of the art, okay.
With a Sat Nav holder on the window,
it's good isn't it?
That's perfect tech,
I think.
Yeah?
Yeah.
That's a good effort
at improvisation.